[inaudible]
joining me today is an evolutionary psychologist and author and associate
professor at the University of New Mexico.
Jeffrey Miller.
Welcome to the Rubin report to Dave.
Great to be here.
Good to be with you,
my friend.
Uh,
you know,
I realized I've had evolutionary biologists on the show.
I've had Bret Weinstein and Richard Dawkins.
I've had psychologists on the show,
Jordan Peterson.
I've never had an evolutionary psychologist.
Never.
No.
For many of us,
how many of how many are there were almost extinct.
Um,
the big international conference we get maybe 300 people versus like a big
neuroscience conference will be 30,000.
That's gotta be a tough crowd.
It's a tough crowd.
Um,
we get a lot of flack from all directions,
but I would,
I wouldn't want to do anything else.
It's an,
it's an awesome field and,
um,
I can't imagine anything more fun than studying human nature for a living.
Yeah.
And you're studying and I've written about so many incredible topics.
I normally,
I always am proud,
I pride myself on the fact that I usually don't have to look at my notes when
interviewing somebody.
But you've hit so many things that every now and again I am going to be glancing
down cause I don't want to miss anything here.
But usually the way I like to start these is just finding out a little bit of
someone's history,
what sort of brought them to the place of expertise that gets them in that
chair.
So just tell me a little bit about,
uh,
you know,
growing up education,
that sort of thing.
What,
what made you interested in all this?
Oh,
I was born and raised in Cincinnati,
Ohio.
Went to Undergrad at Columbia University.
I studied psychology and biology and just anything that grabbed my interest.
So I kind of started out in neuroscience and I thought the brain's fascinating.
And then I kind of drifted into cognitive psychology,
which is studying human learning and memory and perception and how we categorize
stuff.
And then I got really bored with that,
but I thought,
I don't know.
I'll go,
I'll go ph,
do a phd in that.
Anyway,
so I went to Stanford,
started doing cognitive psychology,
but when I was there,
I met a,
these two brilliant,
um,
postdocs who were working with my advisor lead a cause muddies and John
[inaudible] who had just come from Harvard and they basically invented the field
of evolutionary psychology right there at Stanford in front of my nose.
Hmm.
From the ground up.
And they were like,
we're going to take evolutionary biology,
anthropology,
cognitive psychology,
merge them all together and make this new science of human nature.
So let's slow down for a second.
So how,
what does that say that this is look like?
What does that even mean when they're talking about this?
How do you take these things that are thought of as their own institutions and,
and you know,
put them into one box?
It's basically like the,
the key insight is if you want to understand human nature,
whether it's anything human sexuality or emotions or how we relate to other
people or other groups,
you can always ask the question,
where did we come from?
What challenges that our ancestors face in terms of surviving and reproducing
and raising kids?
And what exact structure did those challenges have?
Like what was ancestral life like?
We don't know every,
every detail,
but we do know a lot from anthropologists who had studied hunter gatherers.
We know a lot from primatologist who have studied,
um,
chimps and Bonobos and gorillas and orangutans.
And you can kind of triangulate on a picture of prehistoric life and figure out,
yeah.
Like why do we fear certain things,
snakes and spiders and bears and whatever.
Well,
it's because there were certain selection pressures.
Like if you don't fear those things,
you die.
Why do we look for certain things in mates when we're choosing sexual partners?
Well,
if you don't look for those things,
then you have bad relationships and bad kids,
et cetera.
So it's a way of looking at the past to inform our understanding of the present.
Um,
and that's not what most of psychology does.
So it's quite a novel kind of approach.
But I think we've got,
we've gotten enormous leverage out of it.
Was there pushback from people within each discipline going,
Whoa,
we've got all the answers right here.
Why do we want to put these things together?
Cause I would imagine there's always a certain inherent competition amongst all
of these different disease.
Yeah.
The evolution biologists kind of hate it.
Because that was to be my next question since I know there are a couple of those
guys,
they're
happy to go,
here's how other animals evolve.
They're happy to go.
Here is how the human body evolved.
Here's how the human immune system involved.
But once you got above the neck,
then they're like,
you're just going to make trouble for us in biology because that's where things
got politically controversial is when you start explaining human behavior or
individual differences are sex differences or human emotions and stuff like
that.
So the violence just don't like it.
The anthropologists had a lot of the same issues.
Like we've spent the last century trying to get anthropology kind of away from
biology in a way.
So please don't drag us kicking and screaming back into that.
Yeah.
That swamp of controversy.
Um,
but we just kind of plowed ahead.
And,
um,
and I think it's been a big success story and in the sciences in the last 30
years.
So what were the things that were intriguing to you that had sort of board you
from the other discipline?
More that
I think that the fact that sexuality is central to evolutionary biology and
evolutionary psychology,
you know,
it's how how we get our genes in the next generation is choosing mates and
having babies and raising,
raising kids.
And if you ignore that you ignore,
I think one of the core driving forces in human nature and human culture.
Now,
most of psychology kind of ignores,
uh,
may choice and sexuality and reproduction,
um,
except insofar as it's kind of like seen as politically relevant.
So like you'll get a little bit on while their sexual discrimination against
certain kinds of groups,
which is important to address like gay and lesbian rights and,
and so forth.
Um,
but they don't really see it as central to,
um,
who we are into what motivates us.
So do you see it as,
as the real pillar of what's motivating us?
Like if we were sort of looking at this in concentric circles?
I think it depends.
Yeah.
Where you're at in life.
I think for young single people,
what we call mating effort,
like the attempt to attract other people,
whatever your sexual orientation,
that drives an awful lot of behavior,
how you dress,
what I ideas you adopt,
um,
why you bothered to learn things,
why you bother to get credentials.
I think a lot of that is driven by meeting effort,
but then if you settle down and you're in a longterm monogamous relationship,
you don't kind of need to do that stuff.
But that's exactly when people get lazy.
That's where people let themselves go.
Right?
Um,
they don't say in shape,
they dress more sloppily.
They kind of don't bother reading like serious nonfiction anymore.
Um,
why?
Because a lot of that sort of creative display has already accomplished.
It's its purpose.
So in that way,
that's not a real conflict with evolutionary biology,
right?
Because you want to look your best to get the best mate and all that.
So in that way you guys are on the same track.
So where does that,
where does that DV,
well,
so when biologists talk about courtship displays and here's the bowerbird
building its power and we talk about like ideological displays and here's people
showing off their virtues through virtue signaling,
the biologists know exactly what we're talking about and we know exactly what
they're talking about.
It's just
often they don't want to get in the trouble that that follows if they kind of
make these analogies
two clearly.
Have you had any of these conversations with Bret Weinstein?
Not Directly.
No.
I think I'm going to have to facilitate that one probably.
That'd be a lot of fun.
Yeah.
Yeah,
we'll do that for sure.
So it's interesting.
Okay,
so let's,
let's focus on the sexuality parties for a little bit because it seems like so
many things that we used to be able to talk about we suddenly can't talk about
or that academics are self selecting out of and things of that nature.
Now,
I said to you right before we started,
you're one of the few people I see on Twitter and I'm like,
oh he kind of gets what Twitter is cause you put out some smart stuff.
You're kind of funny on there at the right time,
you know when to go with snark and all of those things and that to me the only
way
that you would be able to have any of these conversations online.
I think social media is actually really good for addressing some of these very
tricky issues like human sexuality and how it's playing out in the modern world
as long as you do it with humor and self deprecation and a little bit of
absurdity,
which is what I try to do in my Twitter game,
right?
Because if you approach it like well here's the next paper on like sex
differences or the next paper on how courtship works or oh awesome.
A new virtue signaling paper.
People will quickly tune out on the last off often think,
well,
you're just kind of being doctrinaire here.
But the thing you quickly realize if you study evolution at all,
his evolution is a very weird process that often produces completely absurd
results,
right?
You Watch any David Attenborough natural history,
you know,
documentary and it's like these animals are insane.
What they're doing is crazy and humans are no different.
Yeah.
And if you don't have a sense of that absurdity,
then it's very easy to get terribly,
terribly serious and censorious and ideological and that really kept the hides a
lot doesn't,
it's going on.
That doesn't really help anybody.
Yeah.
All right.
So let's,
let's pause on sexuality for a second.
I don't want to get off that topic so to speak,
but um,
let's just do the two minute,
uh,
Twitter portion of the show.
Is there a evolutionary explanation to the way we're behaving with each other?
Is there a psychological explanation to the way we act one way on this medium
and another way on another medium and,
and how that has evolved because of communication?
It's a great question.
And I think honestly,
social media blindsided everybody.
I don't know anybody in the 90s in psychology or any behavioral science who's
going,
here's what the Internet is going to turn into,
right?
It'll become this massive global system of very rapid fire,
interactive,
snarky virtue signaling that drives everyone not signed yet.
We can't give it up.
Yeah,
I know.
Villain k Dick probably wouldn't thought that.
Maybe nobody else.
Yeah.
Okay.
Dick,
maybe William Gibson,
a few other folks kind of add the insight.
But honestly nobody was derived and kind of from first principles.
Well,
we are a social primate and we love to gossip and we love to show off our,
you know,
our,
our virtues and our intelligence to each other.
And therefore obviously there'll be this thing called Facebook and Twitter and
whatever,
and it will
play out in this way and moreover it will revolutionize politics or culture in
some way.
No,
nobody thought that.
So we can come up with post-talk reasons why that might've played out that way.
Um,
but I went on,
only do that with a very high degree of humility.
Like,
I don't know.
Now that we're here,
you can kind of a little bit make sense of it that well.
So it looks like you can see the evolution,
um,
Twitter,
you know what I mean?
Where you now see people,
I'd like to include myself in that,
where they're trying to clean it up a little bit is like we all did this unknown
thing of snark and everyone was trying to destroy each other and one up each
other in virtue signal about the things we care about and all that.
And it's like now I'm seeing a growing group of people that are like,
Whoa,
how do we deal with reality in the confines of social media?
But when the Charlie and honestly and without just wrecking everything and that
almost strikes me as a evolutionary function and its evolution is happening so
fast and on such a huge scale,
I mean,
who could have predicted that?
Like the more amateurish looking a visual mean is the better it would spread.
Uh,
that's completely bizarre.
Um,
or the fact that I can get more engagement if I do a really surreal poll on
Twitter about something where all four categories are just completely insane.
Like people are more into that than they are.
Like even my snarky comment about political issue x or y.
So what does that tell you about the psychological state of how we interact with
these things?
They like the main ones really interesting.
It's not the sleigh he produced thing,
you know,
really sharp looking images that go viral.
It's,
you know,
a frog on up black and white idiotic thing or crudely drawn yes.
Or that tree or whatever.
Like there's something really there to that.
The about how we react to images to this.
Also something kind of charming about the artlessness and amateurish quality.
It's almost like if I'm kind of fascinated by standup comedy and the Standup
Comedians who are overly slick or never that funny and the ones who are a little
bit Shambala like Steven,
right back in the 80s,
hilarious.
And he looks,
he looks like he's always on the edge of complete failure or a psychotic break.
And yet that's what makes it work.
Or I guess Seinfeld's,
you know,
in the 90s,
um,
to show was also kind of has this artless quality.
Yeah.
All right,
so let's jump back.
So now it's getting harder and harder to talk about these things.
There's a set of people that think we're all exactly the same and then at the
same time they're obsessed with all of our differences.
I mean,
this is what seemingly is the most potent idea of the day right now.
Um,
what are,
what are the things that you're thinking about in realm of sexuality
right now that are intrigued?
I'm thinking,
I'm especially concerned about the fact that nobody seems to know what a
successful longterm relationship is.
Seriously gonna look like in the early to mid 21st century.
That we don't really have a script for that we've kind of inherited,
you know,
the script of monogamous lifelong marriage,
but nobody really believes that that is going to kind of solve all of our
problems.
And people don't enter enter into that very early in life.
They spend their teens and twenties doing casual dating.
What is that like?
Nobody quite understands what the rules are,
the ethics of that are,
and that at a certain point you kind of get tired of that and you find a partner
and you kind of settled down and go,
okay,
we're going to buy into the wedding industry now and do the wedding thing and
the ring and bottle.
But there are all these subcultures in America and around the world that are
exploring all different aspects,
sexuality and kind of how to incorporate new insights into relationships.
Things like,
um,
BDSM or kink or polyamory and open relationships or the whole red pill
manosphere subculture.
Um,
and then on the other side of the quotas,
does that have to do with sexuality?
Well,
it's a certain way of,
of men and women interacting,
right?
The sort of red pill vision of Male,
female dynamics is that there's a really deep sexual polarity,
masculine and feminine.
And if you don't understand that polarity,
your relationships,
if they're heterosexual,
are gonna fail and burnout and not be satisfying to either person.
So there's much subcultures.
They're all,
uh,
exploring different parts of human nature,
human sexuality,
different possible ways to run a relationship.
And I think they all have valuable lessons that we can kind of learn and
incorporate.
Like even if your vanilla and monogamous and straight and you,
you don't believe all the crazy manosphere stuff,
there's still important lessons there.
And that's kind of my interest now is sort of going around and,
and being eclectic and gathering those up and figuring out what,
which of those might be useful.
Do people
stay in those scenes for,
for a lifetime.
So I,
you know,
I could see where somebody,
you'd be in a whatever your thing is and I'm not passing judgment on Ebay,
whatever your thing is,
you do it for awhile and then eventually I guess it sort of is the venue sort of
get tired of it.
So you move on to something more traditional.
Like is that just part of our psychology?
Like nothing kind of lasts forever.
Some people do that.
Certainly there's a,
there's a life profile kind of openness and experimentation where you try a
bunch of stuff in your teens and 20s on a lot of it deviates markedly from the
traditional culture you,
you grow up in and a lot of that um,
hurts and it doesn't work and it's heartbreaking.
And then a lot of people kind of drift back into the mainstream.
On the other hand,
you got people who marry young and they try the,
the standard vanilla monogamy thing and to their thirties,
forties,
50s and then go,
this is not working.
I need something different,
better,
more open,
whatever.
And I think,
um,
it can go either way.
You know,
the psychological research on all these subcultures is lacking.
We don't know even which lasts longer.
A monogamous relationship or an open relationship.
Everybody,
we don't know.
There's not good data on that.
Huh?
There's lots of anecdotes.
There's examples on both sides,
but I think it's
almost scientific misconduct not to ask those questions and instead to ask like,
let's do,
you know,
study on which alcoholism treatment works.
Let's do the 5000th study on that before we do the first study on what kind of
relationships last longest.
So basically because you think if we could address some of those issues first,
perhaps the studies that we're focusing on unrelated out as well as him in the
rest.
Yeah,
relationship satisfaction is really,
really important to people.
Um,
but it's one of the things that's,
it's not entirely taboo to study it,
but it's pretty hard to get federal research funding to look at something that's
kind of a cornerstone of American wellbeing.
So when that New York Times article came out about Jordan Peterson and they said
he was forward forced monogamy,
which in effect just means marriage.
And if you use the couple of times in the times before just to me marriage,
but everyone thought that man he wanted Jimmy didn't change to be dragged around
by their husbands.
The,
the argument that people that are for enforcement I,
we are married basically make is that this is the best way to build a sort of
functioning healthy society and that you can reproduce and have other
generations and all of those things.
You just think we don't have enough information basically or enough,
um,
all well enough study on the information to know if that really is the best way
to build a
human society.
Right?
We don't know.
There's,
there's good reasons to think that um,
monogamous marriage has been important and every major civilization.
Like it's kind of the most common way to arrange pair bonding.
Um,
and I'm sure Jordan Peterson has read the same articles I've assigned even in my
polyamory class.
That's about here are the benefits of monogamous marriage and there are many
benefits of it.
The question is once you have contraception,
once you have safer sex and STI testing,
once you have paternity testing,
once you have a lot of other,
um,
technologies,
right,
the console,
some of the same issues that monogamy used to solve,
then what is monogamy still optimal probably is for a lot of people.
Probably is for love.
How much of it do you think just comes down to how you're wired?
I think there's a lot of that.
Some people are just wired to go,
man,
I just want a pair bond.
I want my mate and I want to keep it simple and that's good enough for me and I
will get a lot of companion at love and attachment and it'll last a long time.
A lot of people are very happy with that and that's great.
But a lot of people either want more sexual novelty and variety or they have a
higher tolerance for sexual jealousy,
um,
or they just kind of get bored and longterm relationships.
And I think those people should not be prescribing like rampant polyamory for
the Naga musts,
but the monogamous shouldn't necessarily be prescribing like our way is the only
way for everybody else.
So I wonder how this is all related to the gay community because I don't know,
dare I mentioned the name Milo,
but when I had my low on my show years ago,
really before he was Milan,
so to speak,
um,
we got in,
we had about a half hour chat on this where me as the married gay liberal and
him as the unmarried gay conservative,
which is already sort of a flip on things.
His argument was that he wasn't really for gay marriage because he felt that by
being the outsider,
the gays have come up with art and creativity and music and comedy and all of
the that incredible like just gestalt of it all that made this incredible
community,
like a diverse community in the right sense of diversity.
And my argument was,
well,
you've got to at least give people the opportunity to be equal under the law so
that they at least have a choice.
I'm not denying that the gay community has come up with all sorts of incredible
stuff.
Yeah.
But like you gotta make them equal and then let them go either way on that.
Okay.
Yeah.
Do you think there is legitimacy to that?
And do you,
have you done or have you seen any studies on what the effects of the marriage
on the gay community have been?
I haven't seen a whole lot,
but I guess it might be too soon.
I mean,
my understanding,
some of this comes from Dan Dan's habits,
right?
Is that a lot of gay couples have a kind of monogamish relationship where it's
like we're pair bonded,
we love each other,
but there's also a negotiated agreement that we can have outside lovers once in
a while under certain conditions that we kind of mutually agree to see.
It's funny,
I hear
that all the time and I don't know,
advocate couples that I know that are,
that are married or you know,
really yeah.
Together.
I don't know ones that are like that or at least that I know that they are like
that.
Let's put it that way.
But I know that this is,
uh,
something that's tossed out there so we can go with this for so,
but I'm sure there's variety and I'm sure that there's also kind of social
assortment,
right?
So that the more monogamous gay,
lesbian couples will kind of be more comfortable with each other and they might
know those crazy monogamish folks down the road,
but,
um,
or you just don't know your friends that well.
I mean,
anything's possible.
Yeah.
And honestly,
it's not that different from like the way,
um,
even heterosexual relationships work in a lot of Europe where a lot of those are
tacitly monogamish and there's a sort of understanding that,
um,
monogamy doesn't necessarily mean sexual exclusivity for either partner.
Um,
America is extremely puritanical and kind of rigid about that.
And we think,
um,
anything that happens outside the pair bond is almost by definition unethical.
Um,
and there is research on sort of anti polyamory stigma where people actually are
more prejudiced against people in open relationships.
Then they are against almost any other group.
Um,
in terms of orientation or race or religion or,
or anything.
Um,
that might be gradually changing,
but I think it's a,
it's a huge social problem,
especially among Gen z and younger millennials.
[inaudible]
yeah.